hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play penumbra overture as you know
I just whipped the butt of this little
doggy found a key found a locked door
lots of stuff ooh instructions lighter
Plus fuel equals fire no way op and
they're mine
uh-huh locked from the inside here
chattering yeah oh I'm sure it's gonna
be good you know yeah yeah there we go
okay what's this uh let's see I have no
idea
nothing even a genius like me couldn't
figure that out
oh I got some rocks I can always use
some rocks wonderful puzzles nearby
there's some rocks provided easily here
yeah
ah shut up
uh-huh but over what uh yeah boo-boos
give me booth I can't get loose their
cage give me my rock who wants some yeah
yeah open up uh open up all right fine
um take a look with me
oh I can't Yeah right where are you
puppy oh oh I'm not scared
up more rocks bring it on
who's there who's out there no one
nobody
and go to this supposed office that this
sign told me is over here whatever uh
where was I
I been to the office am I going is there
a map uh ah shut up
not Fraidy you Mon why won't you open I
don't even see what's blocking you
nothing uh open I said open okay
all right God diagram ah can I mix
anything people lighter back strand nope
yeah okay yeah sorry sorry my smartness
level is dropping
all right there's my journal to-do list
locked or OGG noises ah ah ah I'm making
myself look bad
shut up doggie you're not even a little
bit of a threat Oh what did I miss what
did I miss anything in here yeah
oh I'm a bad read right
nothing nothing nothing whole lotta
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
whatsoever it's a ray of sunshine right
go back to where I was maybe I missed
something in there
map you know show me anything useful
whatever what do we got what do we got
ah that's no good uh-huh I need to get
out I don't even know this guy's name
I'm a comb Johnny Johnny get your [ __ ]
together got to work together here uh I
know this is real exciting for you guys
oh right oh oh the box of rocks of
course betray me box of rocks huh
get out of here get out of here yeah
there we go
yeah ah ah there we go oh so smart shut
up oh okay I'll follow it cuz I'm super
ha oh ah ah oh
okay still not scared oh look at that ah
the BOP died almost piss on Babette 30
years oh this is his dad does his dad
forecast rusty crude nope they're not
coming for you uh-huh yeah
that was your mistake yeah made a lot
mistakes man did specimen oh of course
bizarre scientific experiments of course
yep yep yep up neither do i mm-hmm
uh-huh oh oh yeah uh-huh
that's nice yep lucky lucky lady luck
fantastic
all right he's crazy his dad's crazy Oh
what's this the pretty old bags
what bags on what oh what's that
deadly deadly steam yeah whatever not
even a problem you know so it's a lie
human voices spiders are so tasty yep
I'm sure
marks a man wall past month edible
friends yeah yeah lots of spiders uh-huh
yep yep yep yep yep you're gonna die
that doesn't seem good oh yeah yeah ah
get off Oh Oh what what gasps oh no a
bullcrap guy dupit steam yeah you're
mummified dog don't cares about you
right totally a [ __ ]
go ah bad ah okay okay ah go go go
yeah I'm the man oh right what do we got
here little door action going on ah
huh top food me to use my muscles
I said punk [ __ ] BAM
yeah so strong didn't stand a chance
alright I know this so smart box chest
yeah bad a reason who needs a flashlight
I'm not even using one oh yeah yeah ah
Wow
don't do that losing blood from Steam
that makes sense
ah alright who else is here no one
everyone run away from me oh look it is
this looks important taking totally mine
yeah get here no one knows you don't
know oh oh oh
huh okay all right
that's something oh I get it
I'm smart it's Marty smart smart ah oh
well thank you yeah I could have done it
but yeah whatever
ooh oh hello ah I don't look good
never seen this much blood for I've seen
10,000 times as much blood yeah who's
caught by me and my fists Yeah right
Oh finding spiders oh boy
oh don't tell me there's a big spider Oh
Oh God Oh
maybe there's no number oh oh oh oh oh
all right we got you nothing nothing
nothing
a lot of nothing like usual story of my
life Oh sad Oh Ben oh oh oh oh oh ah oh
oh their tongue just line there Oh
disgusting all right give me a pencil
y'all don't we got here
tuna door oh hello
oh right I'm going to pause it here
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you in part 3 of let's play
penumbra overture bye bye